i wasn't experienced enough i was too
young you're just branded thick
nick jones the founder and ceo of soho
house with an empire of private clubs
around the world it's the most see and
be seen type of place not everyone gets
it
your upbringing is particularly
compelling to me because you were
somewhat counted out i'm hugely dyslexic
people didn't understand that you were
just branded thick
wow there was not much choice for me
you've created a business which brings a
lot of people joy that first soho house
on greek street why did it work
i wanted to prove that hospitality could
be done differently i can't think of a
time when i was thinking about making an
aspirational brand i've always been
obsessed about the member and that was
always my number one thing they've
created that
if you don't make mistakes you're not
pushing yourself you're not taking
yourself out of your comfort zone maybe
i was trying to prove to my family that
i i could do this and i think that's an
invaluable lesson
at what point does that desire to prove
something need to be contained because
it might come at the expense of like
life balance
um
a very good question and i think
so without further ado i'm stephen
bartlett and this is the diary of a ceo
i hope nobody's listening but if you are
then please keep this to yourself
[Music]
nick
thank you for being here um i have to
say i'm a big fan of the the business
you've created and the i know you don't
like the word but the brand you've built
um for many many reasons that i'm
excited to get into maybe because i'm a
marketeer but maybe also just because
i'm a customer someone and someone that
loves the the soho house um brand but
where i wanted to start with you is
where i always start and your your um
your sort of origin story your
upbringing is particularly compelling to
me because
um
by many accounts
even your own you were somewhat counted
out
is that true
well my childhood was
i don't think i'd say i was counted out
i was
you know
in a nice middle class family where i
had two older brothers and a sister
younger sister mum and dad
but
my two older brothers um were you know
they were the sort of stars they were
they were great at school they were good
at sport and i was a bit not so good at
sport and not so good at school and
it was a sort of different sort of um
sort of childhood that
i suppose that they had and um
yeah i think it probably put me in good
stead but at the time it was probably
quite tricky when you say not so good at
school what do you mean specifically
we're just really bad at exams yeah i'm
i'm hugely dyslexic and um so i find
spelling really difficult i find
pronunciation difficult i find
um
you know all sorts of things difficult
at school i mean i've since learned that
dyslexia is the greatest thing to have
and but at school it isn't but i was
lucky enough
that my mum was all over it and it was
discovered that i was dyslexic at the
age of 12 which is very young for a lot
of people are still discovering
you know contemporaries of mine are
still discovering a dyslexic right now
in
the age i am which is 58. so
i
i was i was lucky and i got support and
i
sort of got through school by
weird things like they they'd give you
extra hours on your exam
but i didn't need that i i i only needed
half the amount of time anyway to fill
up the paper because i didn't have
enough information so
so to get another hour was just another
hour just fiddling around with your
pencil so
um yeah the perception towards dyslexia
today is
is it's quite a common thing and people
understand it a bit better but back then
i'm assuming people didn't really
understand what it was or there was a
stick was there more of a stigma yeah i
think so you're just branded thick
and you know because if you couldn't
read or you couldn't um write proper i
mean my handwriting is
still very not i try and avoid
handwriting of every possibility so it's
still
um really bad and i've i think yes
people because people didn't understand
it there but people understand it now
and people talk about it and
they should talk about it and it's
to me it's you know if you have dyslexia
you look at things very differently
because you have to look at things
differently
you have to simplify things and
by simplifying things i think that gives
you
a different perspective on things when i
say counter that i mean more in the
sense of um you didn't believe that you
would be a success when you were older
because of the
because especially when you're at that
young age you assume that those that are
getting the the best grades and spell
the best and do math the best are going
to be rich and successful and then
there's us as everyone else
so at that young age you didn't see you
didn't envisage you would be a
quote-unquote success
i it didn't i didn't think either way i
was just sort of thinking of just
getting through school and and and i
wasn't really planning that if i was
going to be a success or not a success
and
i i think that's a interesting
um
how you define success um and i don't
think success is just been successful
you know running a business or creating
a business i think it's it touches all
sorts of things
was there um
when i was reading about your parents
dinner parties that seemed to be the
first
inspiration for what you would later do
in hospitality and restaurants and
creating experiences for others was that
the first sort of spark of inspiration
for you yeah um i i i was
while my brothers were on the sports
field i
weirdly like doing the supermarket shop
i with my mum you know i found
supermarkets fascinating i found food
fascinating i then found the whole
preparation of how to give people a good
time
you know fascinating and
you know i loved watching
how you how you could create an
environment where people had a laugh and
fun
and was that what your parents were
doing well yeah they i'm not all the
time i mean occasionally they did it but
um
but when they did do it it was you know
i'd love to be
part of them trying to create a fun
evening and i think that's probably
where i suddenly realized that you know
hospitality was the route for me um
because i you know we're going back a
long long time um you know this was you
know i'm 58 now and i was sort of 13 at
the time and
and i was i used to
you know go to the local sports club and
work behind the bar you know as i would
clean the glasses and weirdly i enjoyed
that i enjoyed the interaction with
people i enjoyed seeing people just have
a have a nice time and and back then
people were not going into hospitality i
mean it was really at the bottom of a
ladder of of industries that people went
into so
i thought that was an opportunity
it's funny because i've sat here with
them jimmy carr and lots of comedians
and when i hear about their sort of ins
and inspiration for becoming a comedian
it tends to root back to them being
younger and it being the thing that they
would see create the most joy in their
home
so
in the case of jimmy carr and russell
and russell howard and a few of the
other comedians i've sat with they tell
me the story about like the thing that
would make my parents the happiest was
when i would tell jokes so that was this
sort of psychological reinforcement that
led me to be a joke teller for the rest
of my life and when i was reading about
those those dinner parties that your
parents had i was i was and also
confounded by the fact that you you know
you said in your own words um you didn't
feel like there was a lot of
conventional opera um avenues available
to you because of your dyslexia
that that was the
the combination of factors that caused
you to
well and and i really had to i mean when
i was at school i because i wasn't good
at getting exams i had to rule
university out i had to
there was there was not much choice for
me you know there was a person with very
few o levels as as they were called then
and i think i got an e in a level and i
scraped through on economics i think and
you know with that there there was
there was really
not a lot of choice and you know my
careers master at school sort of said i
think it's catering nick you know so
when my when my chris master said that
i've i i sort of thought and also the
fact that i thought there was real
opportunity in this and
my my dad owned a small um insurance
broking company and
my brothers went into work there and
i think my dad was keen for me to go and
work there but i i didn't find insurance
very exciting
i still don't
and i didn't find
that world of working in the city and
insurance and being an insurance broker
interesting at all so
i i did have that as an opportunity but
i
really felt i wanted to try hospitality
and catering as you as you started your
journey into hospitality and catering
did you start to at any point figure out
that you were you had some kind of area
of brilliance there was something you
were good at compared to others no i
remember clearly the first no i did the
answer to that was is definitely no um i
my my my first day i i worked for trust
house forte i was a management trainee
and it was a five-year course and i i
applied to the savoy management um
training course to start with and
they
i i remember it to this day the
interview i had um and i just froze i
couldn't speak i was so nervous i i
absolutely froze and because i was a
pretty shy kid and
you know i i was shy at 17 when i was
going through these interviews and i
just was it i just got stage fright i
just couldn't my mouth no words came out
of my mouth
and i didn't get into the savoy
management course but then i applied for
trust house forte and luckily when i
went for the interview i was able to
talk and i got onto a
a five-year course and my
first part of the course was a year in
the kitchens and it was at st george's
hotel in langham place which is just
here in london
off oxford street and
i arrived and the chef looked me up and
down
and he he he he he called me a nickname
which i'm not gonna say
it began with a c and and um he threw a
sack of potatoes at me which landed in
my belly and he said peel them and so i
went off to the viera where you peeled
the potatoes and i hadn't really ever
used a knife before and the first one
the first potato i cut my my my my
finger and i thought oh god how do i
hide the high disk and the water i was
putting the potatoes in was getting
redder and redder and redder and i and i
thought oh no this is my first day and
the nickname
stuck and i
i was really sort of learning on the job
which i think is a really great way to
learn anything and i kept making
mistakes but i ca i was determined to to
sort of fit in to the kitchen because it
was an environment you know because i
came from this sort of cotton wool
um middle class background and then
going into the kitchen into the early
80s where where you know if
they it was long hours and and and they
they you know someone who comes in with
a slightly posh accent and you know they
very very very very it was it but it was
a it was a good moment it was a good
moment for me
was it um
what was it about that
sounds pretty horrific sound and i've
having worked in the kitchen my mum had
a restaurant at a very young age i
started working there at seven super
high stressful people always complaining
it's hot in there
um that and i mean people weren't
throwing things at me and calling me the
c word but it wasn't it was really
unpleasant so i'm wondering what in that
context like
despite of all of that tickled your
fancy do you know what it was it was
i was coming out my shyness i was
learning how to get on with people and
you know i was i went to a private
school i was surrounded by people who
went to private school which is seven
percent of the population and
by going into the the the the um kitchen
you you really learnt to really get on
with everyone and
and i think that's an invaluable lesson
and i
really became friendly with a lot of the
chefs and would go out with them at
night and
i just enjoyed it and even though it was
hard i just enjoyed the environment i
enjoyed creating food i enjoyed the buzz
i enjoyed i didn't mind the heat i
didn't mind the fact that it was it was
it was long hours i just enjoyed it if i
had spoken to maybe your colleague or
someone that was maybe above you in a
line manager at that time and said what
isn't it good at what would they have
said to me
i i'd like to think
um not peeling potatoes or making
porridge but
you know getting on with people and
being part of a team and and getting
stuck in
you said earlier that dyslexia was um
is actually a great gift
can you explain why um why you've now
come to believe that that is a real sort
of superpower for you
well
i i i wouldn't say it's a superpower but
i i i talk a lot about dyslexic because
i really want people to feel that if
they have if they get the tests and
they're dyslexic i don't want them to
ever feel bad i want them to feel good
and go well this is a huge opportunity
because i think when you look at things
differently and the reason one thing
being dyslexic i have to simplify
everything all the time i have to i have
to i want something on one sheet of
paper i don't want it on four sheets of
paper i want i i want everything to be
scaled down and simplified and i think
we live in a world where everyone's over
complicating things always and and you
know and it doesn't matter what area of
the business i work in now whether it's
the designers or the chefs or tech
people you know
it's all over complicated and i spend a
lot of my time just editing down and and
and simplifying it and i think dyslexic
being dyslexic has made me do that you
know because it's the easy route because
complication panics me and confuses me
so i spend a lot of time simplifying and
i think when you do simplify things
people understand it they get it
they like it
yeah so true someone once said to me
that phrase i always forget which is um
if
someone's ability to simplify something
also correlates their ability to truly
understand it and typically when you
meet these like salesmen
that are um trying to blag you in some
way they purposefully overcomplicate
something and sometimes they don't
actually understand what they're saying
but distilling it to simplicity gets it
closer to truth and it's it's also a
sign that the person communicating it
really truly understands the essence of
the idea or the concept
you by 22 you started your own
restaurant chain
well correct i went around lots of
departments within trust house 48 from
front desk to bar to
to
to housekeeping i was a housekeeper at
the you know clean the rooms at the
westbury hotel in conduit street
i i was a barman at brown's hotel in
albemarle street um
and yeah i remember clearly um you know
serving being the barman and i remember
making cocktails for george bess that
was that was a highlight of he was such
a nice guy and
and and i suppose at that time i always
thought the determination was to open
something to to open my own restaurant
this is you know i want to learn this
and then i ended up doing marketing at
trust house forte and then i was
marketing manager at grover the house in
in part lane and it wasn't because i was
brilliant at it it was you know i was
cheap you know
i just was i was i didn't just cost a
lot of money and they could that's what
they were looking for at that precise
moment and but i always when i was
working there i was always working on a
plan to to
you know not work for trust house forte
which was a big
big hotel company and i was thinking you
know i want to get out of this at some
stage i don't want to keep going on the
ladder when you know you keep getting
put you hopefully i would have kept
being promoted into other jobs but and
then it would have been too difficult to
leave so i want to go when i'm still
relatively at the bottom and then i i
went and tried working in fast food
restaurants or sort of
casual restaurants so i went to work to
maxwell's and covent garden as a night
manager i then i then went
to work at pasta mania as a sort of
junior manager and then during that time
i was building my plan to open my first
restaurant which was called over the top
and that opened in
1988 and it was
you know
it was i was too young i wasn't
experienced enough um
it was it was terrible
the design which is something i'm
obsessed with now and i love design you
know and i that was my first design
outing and it really was
terrible um the food was you know really
bad you know my friends had to come
you know and that that showed
i really knew who my friends were
because they would come and support me
in the restaurant but it was uh it was
it was it was it was a a good experience
of getting something really wrong
it's not cheap to open a restaurant how
did you how did you fund that well i i
my my dad put a bit of money in family
friends put a bit of money in and i got
the bank to put some money in um so i
was lucky you know i was given that
chance to be able to open my first
restaurant um
and it's something you know you know we
we do a lot now i i love people
doing that when anyone comes to me and
wants to be an entrepreneur and start
something up i really make time to
steven and help them and you know i was
lucky i was given an opportunity um
and
yeah i learned a lot
that i guess
would increase the pressure if you've
got family betting on you
yeah i i think
i never they never made me feel like
that um you know my dad
you know um
i think he was proud that i was trying
to do something i was trying to do
something on my own because he had his
own small business
um but he never made me feel like that
and the other shareholders you know i
think in their head they
when they first came and tried the
restaurant they sort of probably knew
that it wasn't gonna lead anywhere but
actually you know
the the company is still the same
company as it is today it's a it never
went it never it never went bust we we
we we we hang on in there and um
you know eventually open cafe om in 92
um with which was really all the
experience of getting over top so wrong
and let me explain what over top was it
was it was
it you either chose a burger a piece of
chicken a bit lamb or a steak and over
the top of it you could choose one of 10
sauces
the sources were terrible and and and it
was just
it was just
bad
and um
you know uh it it it just sort of taught
me
you know how to manage a business with
little cash and with no cash
how to pay the staff every week how to
use initiatives to try and get more
customers in and i think it taught me
at a very early age you know marketing
restaurants is not the way to solve a
restaurant you just have to make the
restaurant
good because the customer is so clever
they know what good is and they know
what bad is and it taught me that very
early on there was no way that you could
you don't you can't fool a customer they
they they they know and you could walk
into over top and you could sort of feel
you know you could sense that it wasn't
wasn't wasn't wasn't good enough but
what i learned at that time was
it it's
sort of
it
i didn't feel it was a failure i just
thought it was i was on a a journey of
learning and i
really
even now encourage all our people that
making a mistake is not a problem you
know if you don't make mistakes you're
not pushing yourself you're not trying
you're not you're not you're not taking
yourself out of your comfort zone and
so
you know i really encourage people to
think that you know
failure is not what it sounds like you
know it's okay it's just part of the
journey
what did what did that process teach you
about feedback i asked that because in
my first business i was i had this was a
tech business and i was very romantic
about this hypothesis about the way that
i thought my customers would behave and
about the solution that i thought that
they would care about and i spent too
long not listening to their feedback and
ultimately that
was pretty fatal and i just wish earlier
i'd been less romantic and
stubborn almost about what i thought the
customer would want and and listen but
i'm wondering what that first failure
taught you about the importance of what
feedback you listen to and how you
listen to it well i think feedback's key
um
and
people being honest
it's funny being been a brit people are
funny about complaining aren't they
they're
in restaurants they
they think it will offend you they they
think well i'm not gonna i can't
complain to nick about i had a bad meal
last night because he he might be your
man might upset him but to me
you know you can only get better by
getting really honest feedback and
i'm lucky now because i have members who
all have my email address and and and
you know
they if they're not happy they they
email me so i think listening to
feedback is super super important did
you listen to it and over the top
well i could just see it because there
wasn't many people to give feedback to
[Laughter]
i wish there was more customers in there
giving me feedback um but you you know
people did give feedback and and but i
didn't have the tools to be able to get
it better i didn't know you know you saw
i started going down a
sort of yeah
because
we kept running out of money so you know
you kept cutting cutting the
you know the team down so it just wasn't
you know
at the end it was just
me in the kitchen serving and
we even set up a delivery service to try
and try and try and um
uh
boost our sales but that didn't work
i was so um really inspired by you
saying that the customer is smart
and also you alluded to the fact that
the best marketing is word of mouth
yeah absolutely
that that really is at the heart of what
you even do today is is i believe in the
customers yeah i i'm
very lucky that we have fantastic
members who
are loyal and
and
you know they they you know i i if
anyone says that we've done okay or i've
done okay it's for thanks to our members
and
um you know our members of the people
who pushed me from
doing so house you know the originals
our house on greek street where yeah it
worked there were hairy moments you know
when i thought it really wasn't going to
work um and you know it would go quiet
or it would go you know i remember the
first year we opened in in may suddenly
conquered we'd opened in january i
thought oh god that i thought it would
last a bit longer than this and you know
member turned around to me and said well
we're all down at the cam film festival
you know that's where your members are
so i suddenly thought well next year
i'm going to go down and create a pop-up
down there and this was
pre-pop-ups you know this was in 96 and
so we rented a boat um
in the harbour
and
i remember
in fact i remember clearly because there
was there was a lady who still works for
us to this day veronique and
her and i had to fill up this lorry full
of stuff in london to drive down to i
didn't drive the lorry because i
couldn't drive a lawyer but to go down
to the south of france can and we opened
this boat and it was like a temporary
club for the ten days of the cam film
festival and members
you know if they weren't in london they
could come to the club in in the
the boat in the harbour and that
we did that for
lots of years and it was i think our
members really enjoyed that and that
sort of taught me again
where wherever the member was going go
so you know because if i hadn't you know
i was
i didn't understand the film business or
the media business i was in
catering hospitality so i i was i was
sort of new to this and
you know when i first first created the
first ever committee at sarah house you
know i was really knocking on doors and
and phoning people cold calling then
saying do you mind and and you had to
sort of explain what you were trying to
do to get them to come on the committee
and that was where our first 500 members
came from and
and i think there i've always just
listened to the member you know they
they kept saying wouldn't it it's great
this one why didn't you do one in the
country and i go oh let's do one in the
country then so off i go i phone saviles
up and i say any any hotels for sale i
didn't have any money but i thought well
i'm going to go on that route and see
how i could i could um
get get get somewhere in the country and
i
remember stumbling across babington
house and
and i remember it was it was on the
market for um
you know a million million and a half
pounds um this was back in yeah a long
time ago and
and um
i remember driving up the drive and as
soon as you have drive out the drive at
babington you sort of fall in love of a
place and i fell in love with a place
and i thought oh my god how how how am i
gonna get planning permission to turn
this into a hotel and how am i going to
have enough money to buy it
i had
just a small amount of money just to put
the deposit down
and
luckily
the people who were selling it
um
they
they um they said well we want to stay
here for the summer we you know we want
to we want to exchange and then we will
complete in nine months time i thought
yes
you know and then it gave me nine months
um
um to um
to find the money and get the planning
permission and raise the money with our
members to to
pay for the completion
and also to pay for the refurbishment
and
i i sort of just remember even before we
exchanged
the agent phoned me up and said you know
um a higher off has gone in so i was
sort of being gazumped and i thought
well i don't have the money anyway so i
can put another couple hundred grand on
it because
and so i i increased my offer i i got
babington house and
um
you know i was able to raise the money
we and we raised the money through our
members you know
lots of members put sort of
five grand in
um and that's how i was able to get the
money to open babington house so it was
a it was a
led by our members sort of
verb the members helped invest in it you
know they luckily have all got their
money back plus plus and
um
you know then that was the second
thing we opened that first sega house on
greek street
why did it work
you know i was
running the restaurant downstairs cafe
bowen that was my survival cafe bowen
was you know it was the same company as
over the top it was it was it was me
doing everything totally different to
what over the top was so the food was
edible and nice
the service was good the atmosphere you
know and if i was in there last night
and it was you know it made me very
happy because it was packed and it was
fun and
when the building came up
available above cafe berm which is on
greek street in london
i
the landlord pulled me up um
and they said well do you fancy taking
the space above
and i go well what on earth for you know
there was no plan to do a private
members club my plan was
just to survive and make cafe bowen work
after
four years of attempting over the top
and i still do this today i always look
at everything i when people phone me and
say there's an idea i was gonna have a
look and so i said okay well go and have
a look so i wandered around the offices
and it was a small door you know um
on on greek street forty creek street
and
and i thought hmm
and i hadn't been to a private members
club you know i wasn't i wasn't part of
a groucho club i wasn't i wasn't i
wasn't part of that
that that was only the groucho club all
there were all those clubs down in palm
oil i wasn't part of that maybe that's a
good thing yes and i and i i looked
random oh god this is like a home away
from home and and
and
you know god this is this could work how
could i
you know this this this is an idea but i
didn't have any money
so um again and um
i went to see um
my landlord which is paul raymond um and
i went to see him and he said well you
do want to take it i said well yeah i'd
love to take it but what would you
invest because
the family investment and
from over the top they had had totally
enough explain they
they were out you know the banks were
trying to pull out of you know trying to
get their loan back it was
that bit of it was
you know just
it was it was it was that bit of the
family help was done finished
and
so
i thought
well how am i going to raise the money
for this because it's going to be
separate i'm going to have to do this
separately to what cafe bow m is
and so i went to see paul raymond he
said i'm not investing i didn't invest
in other people's businesses and then it
was when i was leaving he said well what
happens if i
put the money in but just added it to
your rent so you ended up with a higher
rent you know a percentage of
the money he put in
was added to my rent and
i thought well to do the fit out to do
fit
um i thought okay well that sounds like
it can work so i set up sewer house it
was it was simple to come up with a name
it was a house in soho the logo was
pretty simple it was just actually it
was it was so simple it was free
buildings three floors
um
and
and
i and but i owned a hundred percent of
it
because
the cafe bowman a lot you know my my
family didn't want anything to do with
it and and the other investors and i
thought well you know when so house
works i'm going to transfer everything
back to the you know the same
percentages as it was as
when it was over the top so i merged the
two companies so
i didn't want um
i didn't want to be a success on one
hand in on on soho and and they were
suffering on cafe bowm and over top so
we merged it all together and
and we
found the members and and and
you know a lot of the people
who opened sewer house in 95
still are part of sower house to work um
you know
a guy
pierre who was a server in
in in um
the blue dining room the the blue room
in the in the restaurant now runs north
america for us and
um
marcus anderson who
it runs our membership part of our
membership team who was a server in one
of the dining rooms so
the guy marcus barwell was a barman in
the circle bar now he's managing
director of south house design so
it's lovely seeing you know people who
are right there at the beginning still
be part of a company now and
it
it but it was
it was a journey as well it was we were
moving into this new area of membership
understanding membership understanding
looking after people and and just
listening to your members because i'm
sort of going back to your original sort
of feedback question so the feedback and
which comes from our members has sort of
really helped us where we are today was
cafe bowen successful when you embarked
on the house journey upstairs
yes
but it was having to be on top of the
disaster of sower house so it was a
quite a lot of there was a lot of sort
of um it was the same company and and so
yes it worked cafe berm worked it gave
me
the confidence to do something else it
it worked because
um
it
it you know it was 30 years ago so and
there weren't many places i don't think
there were many places which
were open to eight in the morning and
closed at three in the morning and you
could go in there and eat whatever you
wanted or just have a coffee or just
have a drink
the kitchen was always open you could
you know drink chunks of beer or you
could have a steak freak or
and we had jazz in the afternoons it was
really
creating it it sort of really created a
real regular following within soho and
it was
the turning point really of the disaster
of overdue
i had a few words to say about one of my
sponsors on this podcast for many years
people have been asking for a
coffee flavoured huel and quite recently
he'll release the iced coffee caramel
flavor of their um ready to drink heels
and i've just become hooked on it over
the last couple of weeks i've been on a
really interesting journey with huel
which i've described and talked about a
little bit on this podcast i started
with the berry ready to drinks then i
moved over to the protein salted caramel
because it's 100 calories and it gives
you all of your essential vitamins and
minerals but also gives you the 20 odd
grams of protein you need and now i'm
balanced between them both i drink
mostly the banana flavor ready to drink
i've got really into the iced coffee
caramel um flavor of heels ready to
drink and now i'm drinking that as well
as the protein make sure you try the new
ready to drink flavors that the caramel
flavor is amazing the new banana flavor
as well is amazing and obviously as i
said the iced coffee caramel flavor has
been a real smash here so check it out
let me know what you think on social
media i see all of your tags and
instagram posts and tweets about huel
back to the podcast so when you look
back then on that so house a lot of
people i'm sure started very similar
style businesses around the time i'm
trying to figure out why sir house went
on to become what it is today what were
the the factors that
in your view you talked about customer
feedback shaping everything but well i
would i would give that accolade to our
members
i would i would say it was the members
who pushed me
and and
yeah when they when we opened in new
york you know
because we i think we'd open the
electorate house with we're about three
then and and someone said well you
should open in new york i'd love this
i'll have a oh yes maybe so
off i go to new york and and and
determined to open a sewer house in new
york first of all look in the re
district of soho
and
couldn't find something going came close
it was difficult learning permitting it
was it was just
difficult and
i remember
we found the warehouse it was an old
electrical warehouse and meat packing
and meat packing
was a very different place to what it is
now
um
it was run down it was you know it was
it was full of sort of
it was full of
really interesting life and and
i remember we found this this this
this warehouse and i thought okay i'm
gonna get get the warehouse and again we
had to raise money to do it so
it was a question of
trying to um how do you get raise money
in new york because we we you know
it was it was a bad time in the uk it
was so i think it might have been a
recession going on so the banks were
you're not gonna we're not lending you
money in new york so i thought okay well
i gotta start raising money again from
our members and from people in new york
to put money into the seller house in
new york
and
um i i
it was everything was nerve-wracking you
know
the week
i was flying out there to try and get
the permit to
be able to allow to open a club in the
in a warehouse
was 9 11. so i arrived on
i think it was a monday evening
and i was nervous because i it was this
big
big meeting on the thursday where in in
front of a local community board to see
whether we'd get permission to be able
to
open up a club and have a license in
this premises
and i was having breakfast
um
on the tuesday morning then the 9 11. um
and i was having a bold egg i remember
it and as i was hitting my boiled egg i
heard this big bang
and i thought what is that so i ran out
on the street and i looked up and i
could see
one of the twin towers with
smoke coming out of it and
i asked um
there's a guy sweeping the street and i
said what happened he said well a plane
went into the side of it and i said well
was it just a
what did it look was it he said it was
an airliner it was so it wasn't like a
private plane
and i thought oh my god so the first
thing i did was phone kirsty my wife um
because she was
in new zealand she was a news presenter
on itn and i said i think maybe you
should get into work
there's something going on here
and and then and then
i
was still out on the street and i saw
the second plane going you saw it coming
yeah
it was coming in from the
river so you didn't actually see it
coming in but you saw the impact of it
coming in
and
and then
you know
that day was it it made me really fall
in love with new york
it's sort of the release resistance of
the people
uh
how how they cope with it how they
it was it was it was amazing the people
of new york that day um and that that
week and
and
anyway
weirdly the community board still
happened on the thursday
and i went up and did my presentation i
said i
i don't know why i'm doing this it seems
irrelevant it seems
not
not
something we should be doing but you
know
you're running a meeting there was a lot
of other
points on the agenda so i was just one
of them and we got our permission um
and
that's how new york started but it was a
big big
sort of
race to find the finance and i was
calling everyone i was i was calling
everyone i did more show rounds of that
that that that warehouse building you
know running up and down the stairs
showing people around trying to be
enthusiastic
and then you know i was sort of getting
to know people in new york and i put
together this hard hat dinner
um
where
i i don't know how it happened and i
don't know
um
why it happened
but
you know the
really well-known people turned up to
this dinner and we had just had a six
burner on the sixth floor and we cooked
some chicken and we laid out the table
in the building site on with a white
tablecloth so it was real grit and
glamour
it was it was and and these people just
turned up and
i remember
david bowie been there
and i'm going
and i remember
i was so nervous i was i i i
and i i started talking to
him and he said
this is a great idea can i buy it
and i said well
there's nothing to buy at the moment but
can you invest in it yes and and so
he was one he was one of the investors
of of of sewer house new york which was
fantastic and and and then
momentum came and we rose raised the
money
everyone
sort of before that was saying a private
members club wouldn't work in new york
you know
people wouldn't pay a membership fee
people
treat restaurants like private members
clubs and
the velvet rope was the big thing in new
york
um
and i wobbled so often about should we
charge for membership and every uh i was
so nervous opening so i had new york and
i remember the opening party
um and
it was raining and they hadn't
finished putting the roof on
and and
people were staying in the hotel and
there was no water so we had to borrow
the showers at the local gym people had
to go down to a local gym for hot water
we had water but there was no hot water
and it was just this
roller coaster of an experience opening
in new york where
we didn't quite have enough money
and
you know the team
you know my we were carrying sheep
sheetrock or it's plasterboard over here
and sheet rock over there
up to the floors to try and finish them
putting the ceilings in and
and it was a it was a it was a it was a
journey but then eventually we opened
and
it worked it so people sort of took to
it
why bother you know like you had a great
business here in london you know things
are going well why why put yourself
through all that pain
um
a very good question and i think
i
could have just carried on doing things
in london but i
there was an ambition in me there was
you know there was this
this thing about being a brit and going
to new york and trying to take the thing
which i loved in london and see if it
worked in new york and it was
and it
and at points it nearly took the whole
thing down
and
but i
really felt at the time that
if it did bring the whole thing down at
least i tried at least i gave it a go
and i wasn't going to be
sitting in a rocking chair thinking i
didn't give it a go so i think there was
a sort of inner something in me which
wanted to see and maybe it was sort of
going back to my childhood when my
brothers were so good on the sports
field or or good at school i was trying
to prove a point
because because i sensed that a lot even
when you had this you know successful
cafe for you then to take the risk of
taking upstairs with an unknown idea
just because someone said it's available
and it's that
you know some people are more like the i
don't know they stay within the zone of
comfort and they just harvest but you
have this hunting
sort of predisposition as well even when
things are going well
so
well
i
there's something inside me um
maybe i was trying to prove to
my brothers my family that i i could do
this and and yeah i
and i do always look at things in a
positive light i do look at things like
you know if i look at a glass of water
i'd say that's half full um not half
empty and
and
and
hospitality i wanted to prove that
hospitality could be done differently
and i think with
cafe bowen
where we opened it all day and it was
chameleon it just kept changing to the
time of day it was and putting jazz on
in the afternoon and just sort of
making it much more customer focused
where
you would go out
40 years ago and kitchens would close at
2pm and you couldn't eat in the
afternoon and
i think that was something i felt i was
onto something to be able to make it
better for the customer and that sort of
took me back to
when i liked helping my mum and dad when
they had people around for supper and i
loved seeing rooms full of people having
a good time in cafe bowen and i loved
laughter i loved people connecting with
each other i loved people enjoying
themselves and i think i just thought
why didn't i just carry on doing this
at what point does that desire to prove
something need to be
contained because it might come at the
expense of like life balance
you know this question i've asked myself
a lot it's like
when you are successful in one thing you
have more opportunities to go and do
more things and then you might end up
being pulled so much by your ambition
and your desire to prove a point or your
insecurities that you then end up
compromising all of these other things
like
friendships and the other things that
make life fulfilling yeah and i it's a
it's a balance i've never quite got
right and
i'm super lucky i have an incredibly
supportive wife kirsty and
she
she sort of
really went on the journey with me and i
know
without her you know i wouldn't be you
wouldn't be asking me on to this podcast
and um
you know so she's been a great support
and my kids
you know were sort of part
of well you know they they had to
come to work they you know when i was
doing the rounds
on a saturday morning or during weekends
i'd have push chairs and toddlers and
you know they were just part of what was
going on and it had to sort of merge
into
one thing and what i've
successfully done is try and de-merge it
and have you know a when i'm at work i'm
at work and when i'm a family i'm with
family and that but that's taken a long
time so the
the
the balance is is something i think all
entrepreneurs
suffer
you say it's a balance you've not
got right what was the indicator that
you didn't get it right how did you know
you didn't get it right what was the
symbol i was always knackered
i was always sort of pretending not to
be
i was always
sort of
yeah um
yeah it was
i was internally coping with all the
pressure where i could but i wasn't
doing that very well
um so
i think it was
sort of
a combination of of of just realizing
that
yeah this was all
consuming it was it was it was really
dragging and and i was very lucky i had
you know great friends who are still my
friends from when i was a kid
and i didn't see them enough and you
sort of in our business hospitality it
is weekends it's nights it's
days it's
it's it's all the time and when you take
it to a different country then you have
to think well the day's just got longer
and then and and it's got five years you
know go to new york got five hours
longer
and so yes it does take its toll what is
that toll you said about coping with
pressure well i i i think
you know i
i sit here today and i think i'm lucky
because i think i got
a great
you know i i have great relationship
with my kids i you know it's my favorite
thing it's been with with the family and
been being been with them all together
um so um
but i think at times when you're
trying to prove yourself i'm trying to
prove that i could work in new york and
america i was trying to prove that we
could open sewer houses and other
parts of the world i i think it it it it
it was hard but
you know you suddenly then do realize
that you have to sort of balance it
was it was there a point in your journey
that was particular so the pressure
becomes so much and you almost feel
within your being whether it's your
health gives out or your your mental
health or you get anxious where you
think this is not
this is not sustainable
i i i never thought it wasn't
sustainable because i'm always such a
positive person but i think
you know kirsty was great you know she
kept saying you know we don't need any
more this is we don't need another house
the world doesn't need another house
nick you know
the
you know you don't need to be on a plane
all the time what who are you what are
you trying to prove
and
and there was a stage where i was
buzzing around everywhere flying here
flying there and and thinking it it was
all making a big difference but
really and i think the pandemic taught
me that was the fact that there's better
ways of using your time
and what are those better ways of using
you well you know
instead of buzzing around on a plane all
the time and spending 12 hours in a city
and then going to another city or doing
one night and one you sort of where
you know the teams are clever enough to
put on a bit of a show for that
that period of time so you're not
actually seeing really what's going on
and it was just smarter ways of doing it
and
and and also having a lot more trust in
the senior leadership team and uh
letting him get on with it and thinking
i didn't have to be everywhere for it to
work and actually often it worked much
better when i wasn't around and
and i mean i
i i you know because they were able to
just get on with it not worry about what
i was thinking all the time
that sounds like great advice for a
younger version of nick at the start of
the house journey what else would you
say um now in hindsight you wish someone
had maybe they said it but you'd wish
you had known
about how to achieve get to where you
are now or further um
but in a more effective whether that
relates to health or finance way what
what would be that advice you'd give to
that nick starting out on the server
house journey
well i've always been
obsessed about the customer the member
and that was always my number one thing
and the people who work for us so they
they were my two obsessions and
i the advice i think i'd give to
a young young young nick would be
you know
let them
take more don't think you have to you
know your team you know put it more onto
your team to get on with it and
don't try and do everything yourself and
also
you know there's a there's a point when
you have can prove yourself that you can
these things can work globally and
you know there's a time when
you know you have to
really properly delegate and let other
people get on with it
what are the you know because one of the
things that server house is known for is
this quote-unquote brand and i know you
don't like that word but this very um
i think i would say it was an
aspirational brand people want to be a
solo house person
how much in intentionality i don't even
know if that's a word has gone into
making that brand
aspirational
i i i can't think of a time where we had
a time where i was thinking about
making an aspirational brand i think it
that's
and if that's people's perception great
i'm really i'm i'm i'm
that sounds good
and
i
i
all i concentrated on what our members
wanted and
they've created that they have created
the the
[Music]
the fact that
you know there's a desirability to be
part of a house and yes we and we and we
got a brilliant team brilliant
membership teams globally we got
we got people who really care people who
have been on the journey for a very long
time
and i think
with their help and with every house we
have a determination to make it better
than the last house you know we always
start with a fresh piece of paper we
don't think well you know let's just
keep repeat repeat repeat we go
new new new how can we make it better
what are we going to change to make this
better what are we going to change to
make it more efficient what are we going
to change to make it better for the
member
and i think
our members really appreciate that and
they see that and they talk about that
and that's probably what's created
what you have just described
what is in hospitality taught you about
life
everything
i
sort of think
you know um it should be the national
service your people should go into a
year in hospitality because
i think
it teaches you so much i mean i spoke
earlier about
me going into that kitchen and
really learning how to get on with
people and from different backgrounds
different countries different different
everything and
i think it really teaches you you know
to be part of a team and there's a
customer there's
all your
you know people you work with in the
kitchen or the person cleaning the
dishes or a person
you know cleaning the rooms it you all
have to work together to make it happen
and i think so
it really
takes the shyness out of you and it
gives you an ability to get on with
people which i think is a really useful
tool i think it's better than a
a maths degree i think getting on with
people i think
um
you learn
you know just useful practical things
like making a bed or keeping a place
tidy or clearing a table of plates and
and and when you when you've got a
family gathering or something you can
suddenly clear the plates and
stack them up or you can
you can you can make a cocktail you know
which is really nice you know you know
that doesn't you don't even if you're
not in hospitality anymore you can still
make a cocktail you can still make a bed
you can still hopefully get on with
people you can still you know clear a
table you you you have to become quite
organized in your mind and i think
hospitality is a very rewarding
industry for that
hospitality is quite a quite a broad
term but at the crux of it what do you
think it is that you're actually selling
to people
what are they buying from you well i
think
what we want our member to do is
flourish you know we want them to
flourish
socially and we want them to flourish
you know at work and i think creating
memberships and you know that
word community of people who
are so like-minded and and
they all have a creative soul and you
put them in in one house you know
that
is like
you know
they bump into each other they talk to
each other i've seen businesses created
i've seen relationships created
friendships created ideas created and
and i think when you put people together
in a space and and and
it that is that is pretty special and
to see that happen in different
countries and different cities to see
members sort of really
using the fact that you go into the
house you can just go into the house on
your own just wander down there and you
know you'll bump into someone you'll
start having a drink with someone or a
cup of coffee with someone or you and
you're sort of you you're in the house
you're part part of that membership and
i and i you know people do it you know a
lot now and you know you can do it
digitally and they use algebra ribbons
and they use all sorts of things and i
think you know being part of cell hats
and you know those 500 members i talked
to you about
earlier you know they're still part of
us they still pay their membership if
they're still here they're still part of
it they don't give it up
and
and so you on one hand they the original
founder members of 27 28 years ago and
then on the other hand you got you know
huge
under-27 membership going into our
houses huge you know it accounts for
to 23 of our overall membership you know
under 27s and
it's it's
seeing in a room
you know the most successful script
writer in one corner
and on in another corner there might be
a struggling scriptwriter who's still
trying to write you know their first
script or you know vr a really
well-known artist or an artist who
hasn't sold a new painter who hasn't
sold their first bit of work
and
you know and taking that and and trying
to think well how can the person who's
done it help the person who wants to do
it and
yeah that's why i'm so passionate about
our mentoring scheme you're where
you know there is so much creativity in
the world and there's so much creativity
you know and and creativity is not owned
by the middle class
it's everywhere and
to
to be able to offer mentoring
to people who are less fortunate who
might not be able to afford a membership
or might not
know
what door to knock to get that
opportunity
is
sort of one of the favorite things that
we're doing my favorite things i'm doing
at the moment is seeing it happen so
going back to what you were saying about
creating
people in a room who all help each other
they all feel like they're looking out
for each other they all want to help
the person who who's down on their luck
or who is
is
is is is starting out or they want to
help the the
the
you know they want to create an idea
with another bunch of members and i
think that that that is special and it
goes back to
seeing people in a room having a great
time and and if our members can flourish
in in their lives if so our house can
just make their lives just a little bit
better then i think that's a good thing
are you naturally shy person
i think so
because it's funny because when i i meet
entrepreneurs there's various different
types of entrepreneurs um
once in a while i meet an entrepreneur
and a founder that's created a really
great business but it's quite i think
the word is unassuming as in they're not
very self-promoting you know you ask
them certain questions about what their
brilliance is for example and
they they don't necessarily point at
themselves they tend to defer it to
others so it just made me it's it's it's
curious because it's kind of
unconventional to me an entrepreneur
that's so
that feels so unassuming in a sense
in terms of
not having a huge ego i guess
um because the question i was going to
ask you and my head is going he's
probably not going to
get a he might defer this to something
else's
you've created such an amazing business
and it's such a wonderful brand and it's
it's admired by people that are
customers and that aren't customers just
for for the business but
i can't seem to get you to tell me
um
why
you out of everyone else that was trying
to do this was successful
because i got the ambition piece i've
got that persistence and that that
persistence that comes from that
childhood sort of maybe chip on your
shoulder but but
but i know there's more
well
i'm i can only tell you what i'm i i
think and i what i i do think is
you know
i i i love what i do i'm lucky i get up
every morning i have a skip in my steps
you know i'm skipping around i'm i'm
looking forward to getting to work i
i
i have a fantastic team around and
um you know i care deeply and if that
all adds up to
it working that's the reason why because
it was never for me a money play it was
more a
a thing that i wanted to try
and make hospitality
you know and that is a
i used to say catering but i've upgraded
it to hospitality and and to make
hospitality a sort of area of where you
can change it you can you know when we
open babington house you know it was a
first country house hotel where you
could get breakfast when you wanted when
there was no rules it was it was it was
you know your your bedroom at badminton
house probably nicer than your bedroom
at home so people would come down and go
well nick you know um
you know where do you get that tv where
do you sky that's new well i'm gonna put
sky in my houses or i'm gonna where'd
you get those sheets and and
so
i'm
not trying to avoid your question here
but i'm just trying to again answer how
i feel and why i do it i did get
something more from that which is just
your care yeah how much you care and
your passion and your care seem to have
a relationship together but and that's
that's so important because a lot of
people would be launching it for money
and then therefore they'd care about
something else whereas you really seem
to care essentially about the customer
experience more than anything else well
i i think i always say to our team as
sort of if
if our people are happy and that's the
members are happy then sort of
everything else will look after itself
because your places will be busy and if
you if you're smart and you're cost
controlled it
it it
everything else should be fine do you
think you're a success
i
i i think i said earlier but success you
can judge success in lots of ways um
you know i'd much rather be judged as a
father than
as
someone who runs a business and
you know i suppose you'd have to ask my
kids that professionally do you think
you're a success i
people tell me a lot and i i suppose i
have to listen to them in in in in in
in their eyes i'm i i i've i've done all
right you know i'm i'm still there i'm
still you know we're still
growing it's you know
sales go up you know it's it's it's a
good business in your eyes
i think so i think if i was to be honest
i couldn't sit here and look at you and
your eyes and say no i don't see what
i've done as something which isn't
successful because because it works and
when things work i presume that's a
success
and so what's next then for for you i
mean
tremendous business all around the world
and it's becoming so much more than just
houses what is the big next mental
challenge ambition excitement
well we're recently public
um
and you know we went public during the
pandemic i'm enjoying that challenge
really yes i'm enjoying it i'm enjoying
dealing with
you know and i
view all the analysts as smart and
and i think it's making us a better
business and i think
um you know so there's a journey on that
you know it's we're only 12 months into
it and people understanding that it's a
subscription recurring income
that
you know a third of our revenues come
from membership and
our our hotels our bedrooms are always
nicely full and we don't have to use
what other hotels have to use to fill
their hotels like booking engines etc um
i i
so i i think
that is a
a an interesting future on how to be
properly successful on the on as a
public company um
and there's so many
more places we can open houses you know
we we haven't even touched africa we've
only dipped our toe into asia we
we
we got we're going to latin america
later this year um to open in mexico so
there's a there's a there's a lot of
exciting new houses opening um and
being a public company
and just trying to get better every day
we have a closing tradition on this
podcast where the previous guest uh
leaves a question for the next guest
and um the previous guest has left you a
question
they have written they don't obviously
don't know who they're writing it for
but here we go um
if you could go back in time and change
one specific moment in your life what
would that be and why
oh
um
i would definitely have come up i
definitely would still would have done
over the top
i i would have done that
um
one specific thing
um
i i think i would have
i would have
tried to get my life
at my
balance between life and and and family
a bit better
why
because
you know running at 100 miles an hour
overtime doesn't always
sort of
you know
achieve everything so i think i think
and i've i've talked on the behalf of
many entrepreneurs and many ceos and
who
just get a bit obsessed and and about
their their world their business and i
think you know you you slightly better
of it if you're not so
if you have a more balanced view
yeah i was actually talking to one of my
friends about this last night that
you'll know um that runs one of the big
big companies in this country that's a
billion pound company and he was we were
having the same conversation about just
trying to remember amongst all of this
ambition that the like the actual most
important question is like are you happy
yeah and and that's one that um i've
definitely lost sight of for many many
years of my life in the pursuit of
building more and more and more yeah and
then eventually loneliness or some other
kind of consequence will show up and
remind me that
i've misprioritized but it's a it's a
great subject now isn't it and i think
people come out with pandemic and they
think there is you know
we want our lives to be slightly more
balanced and i think
i think
you know
that wasn't the case 25 years ago or 15
years ago or when you started your
business it was it was you know it was
that mission and i think
balance is good
well thank you nick thank you so much
for your time the generosity with your
time and uh thank you for creating a
business that i love and that i that i'm
probably at every week at current rate
um and now thank you for being a member
yeah
and you know i think most most of our
team as well i bought memberships for
them as well and um you've created a
business which brings a lot of people
joy but but the thing that i actually
love the most about your business which
is i think is a bit of a dying
um human
maslowa need is community and everything
whether it's the industry i worked in
social media or whether it's other
things or even remote working now seems
to be taking community away from us
which seems to be so integral to like
the huma being a human and so house and
the brand is bringing that back and i
think that's why i would personally bet
on that because i think um regardless of
how the world change and technology and
all of that we're still going to always
um love and have a desire for community
so yeah i agree i agree
the human connection and people getting
together and laughter and ideas and not
doing it digitally doing it in a
physical space is is great to see
thank you
quick one as you might know crafted one
of the sponsors of this podcast and they
make really meaningful pieces of
jewellery this lion piece they've made i
wear all the time along with the little
timepiece the sand timer that i wear
often and the lion piece you might have
seen conor mcgregor has a similar piece
which was custom made for him for me it
represents courage and if you walk
through my house the house that i'm in
right now if you walk six feet in that
direction you'll see a huge lion
portrait if you go upstairs you'll see a
lion portrait if you look behind me on
the shelf near the top there you'll see
a line as well the reason my house and
my life is surrounded by lions is
because they represent courage
calmness and that tenacity that i've
applied to my business success to my
professional life into everything in
between for me the lion has always been
an animal that can be almost a bit of a
contradiction they are so loving and so
caring of their own and can be powerful
and courageous when necessary in order
to achieve what they want to achieve so
if you like me are a big fan of courage
bravery ambition while also being
calm and composed check out this line
piece and let me know if you get it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]